Lynne is with us in Florida hi Lynne
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thank you for taking my call I actually
called you back in February and you
helped me settle a 2010 $12,000 American
Express bills I'm excited to get back in
touch with you today sure how can I help
okay
I have a home that I owe about sixty
seven thousand dollars on but it can
probably sell for 150
and I'm wondering should I sell my home
to pay off my debt that's your personal
residence yes it is and how much debt do
you have 82,000 on what about 59
thousand on student loans that graduate
student loan so it's a six point eight
six point eight percent APR and then six
thousand to my sister and then the rest
on collection debt okay so you've got
twenty fifteen twenty thousand dollars
in collections yes okay what were those
debts credit cards actually credit cards
and then once like eighteen to AT&T past
due bill and yeah okay what's your
income my shovel is kind of small I make
up I bring home an astronaut your
master's degree in criminology okay and
so you're making what now
thirty-nine thousand that includes child
support and I rent out a room in my
house I'm sorry did I say 39,000 3900
per month so about 50,000 a year yeah
okay and so your criminology masters is
not turned into income I should have
made sure not why it absolutely I'm not
even working in that field one it's I I
didn't really have a target for what I
mean I just got the mask
just to get it and I didn't really have
a career path for it and so $60,000 in
debt to get a master's just to get it
yeah I had initially someone I mean I
was planning to go to law school and
could not really afford law school so
the alternative we should get a
criminology degree and I was hoping just
having a master's degree that I would
get able to get out and just get a job
that would pay more that what my
bachelor's was getting me and I just
haven't really found something in that
field no you discovered this for not
really how it works right yeah you don't
just generally get paid for a master's
you get paid for the master's in a
particular field because it shows you
have expertise in that field okay I
think you have a career problem your
career keeps spinning out right and so
I'm gonna send you a copy of ken
Coleman's book I don't think you I don't
think your house is the problem it's not
that far out of line I think you've got
potential to make almost double what
you're making okay and it'll probably
take two or three years to implement
that and to get you into that track but
you need you have a master's degree in
criminology and you know not counting
your side hustles and your child support
you're not even making what a high
school graduate would make should I be
okay that I'm only putting about five
hundred dollars towards debt
particularly my student loans right now
I'm just kind of typing away smallest
the largest yeah I would pay minimum
payments on everything but the little
one and I would attack the little one
but here's the thing
I think our discussion here is all about
your shovel okay it's all about your
career because if I can add $20,000 to
your income it changes this equation
dramatically absolutely yeah and and
what that's going to require is a level
of intentionality applied to your career
choices and developing a career track
that you have never
done in your life to date you're gonna
have to get game on okay let's say this
is what I want to be and it pays $80,000
a year and here's my six steps to get
that and I got to get in a get with
those people I got to get in that world
and I've got to figure out a way to go
make $80,000 a year instead of 35 with
my master's degree and I mean I don't
know the job title to tell you to reach
for but just doing this a long time this
just feels like you're dramatically
underemployed and I think it's got a lot
to do with lack of direction and lack of
consistent direction you keep changing
horses halfway through and looking for
some silver bullet to fix this and you
is yo secret sauce you know there is no
master's degree that's gonna make it all
worthwhile there's no little movement
here that's gonna make it worthwhile
you're the secret sauce to your success
so hold on I'm gonna give you a copy of
ken Coleman's book proximity principle
read through that go read everything can
offer Ken's website start talking to him
on his radio show and he will walk you
into this next phase of your career and
get you to where you want to go but I
think rather than sell your house I know
rather than sell your house I'm gonna
work on your income if I'm in your shoes